>> Tucker: WELL, GOOD EVENING
AND WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
A SHOOTING YESTERDAY AT
youTUBE'S HEADQUARTERS IN
CALIFORNIA LEFT ONLY THE SHOOTER
DEAD.
THE KILLER WAS AN IRANIAN
REFUGEE NAMED NASIM AGHDAM.
LET'S PRETEND THIS IS NOT THE 8
P.M. SHOW ON FOX NEWS.
IT'S SOMEWHERE ELSE.
CNN OR ANY OTHER CABLE CHANNEL
OR NEWSPAPER IN AMERICA.
IF THAT WERE TRUE WE WOULD HAVE
TO DRAW HARD-AND-FAST
CONCLUSIONS FROM THIS TRAGEDY.
WE DON'T KNOW MUCH BUT SWEEPING
DUMB GENERALIZATION ARE THAT THE
MEDIA DO.
WE WOULD DO THAT.
AND WE NEED A SPECIFIC SCRIPT.
WHAT DO WE CONCLUDE FROM WHAT
HAPPENED YESTERDAY?
FIRST THE SHOOTER A WAY WOMAN.
CLEARLY AMERICA HAS A PROBLEM
WITH TOXIC FEMININITY.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THAT PROBLEM
RIGHT AWAY.
THEN THERE IS THE GUN.
WE FOCUS ON THE GUN BECAUSE
NOTHING IS MORE PIVOTAL IN A
SHOOTING THAN THE WEAPON USED.
IT'S ALWAYS THE GUN'S FAULT.
THE IS THAT RIGHT -- THE SHOOTER
IN THIS CASE USED A SMITH AND
WESSON GUN.
THEY NEED TO BE BANNED.
THE SHOOTER WAS A VEGAN AND A
SUPPORTER OF PETA.
LET'S HOPE CNN HOSTS A TOWN HALL
MEETING TO SCREAM AT PETA
SPOKESPEOPLE.
MEDIA OUTLETS ARE NOT RETCH
MEDIA OUTLETS ARE NOT RETC
MEDIA OUTLETS ARE NOT REAC
MEDIA OUTLETS ARE NOT REACHI
MEDIA OUTLETS ARE NOT REACHING
THOSE CONCLUSIONS.
THEY ARE STUPID ON THE SUBJECT
OF FIREARMS.
PEOPLE YELLING AT YOU ABOUT GUNS
ON TELEVISION ARE NOT SURE WHERE
THE BULLET COMES FROM.
THEY ARE KIDS LIKE FIFTH
GRADERS.
THIS HAPPENED YESTERDAY.
THIS IS MSNBC NICOLE WALLACE
MISTAKING THE OPENING OF A SODA
CAN FOR GUNFIRE.
WATCH.
>> I ALWAYS GO BACK TO THE
HORROR OF 9-11 AND THE RELIANCE.
WE ARE IN OUR CORNER MOST OF OUR
LIVES.
I THINK WE JUST HEARD SOME GUN
SHOTS.
NOT GUN SHOTS?
OKAY.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHING].
NO, NICOLE.
PRETTY FUNNY.
SHE LECTURES ABOUT THE SECOND
AMENDMENT.
PETE IS FOX AND FRIENDS WEEKEND
HOST AND A FORMER MEMBER OF THE
U.S. MILITARY AND JOINS US
TONIGHT.
PETE, IT'S A SIMPLE QUESTION.
WE KNOW THE WAY THESE THINGS
UNFOLD AND THE WAY THEY ARE
ANALYZED IN THE PRESS.
WE DRAW SWEEPING CONCLUSIONS
FROM A SMALL SETS OF FACTS.
WHY WE ARE NOT HEARING THAT.
>> WRONG BAD GUY.
A FEMALE, OF IRANIAN DESCENT.
NOT A TRUMP SUPPORTER AND NOT A
MEMBER OF THE NRA.
SHE DOESN'T FIT THE NARRATIVE.
ABC A GLANCING BLOW.
NBC SAID SHE IS APPARENTLY AN
ANIMAL RIGHTS ACTIVIST.
IMAGINE IF AN NRA DID THIS.
IS HE APPARENTLY OR ACTUALLY AN
NRA MINUTE.
NO JUDGMENT OR BLOOD ON THE HAND
NO JUDGMENT OR BLOOD ON THE HA D
HANDS OF A PETA MEMBER.
IT'S ABSURD TO ME TO DEFINE A
POPULATION AS VIOLENT BECAUSE
THEY BELIEVE IN ANIMAL RIGHTS.
LIKES IT'S ABSURD TO BELIEVE
THAT SECOND AMENDMENT SUPPORTERS
ARE VIOLENT.
>> Tucker: THE COVERAGE OF GUN
CRIMES REALLY DID NOT AN EFFORT
TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF GUN
CRIMES.
IT'S AN EFFORT TO MAKE A SERIES
OF PARTISAN POINTS?
>> IT'S AN EFFORT TO IMPUGN THE
SECOND AMENDMENT AND THOSE WHO
SUPPORT IT.
IT DEPENDS ON THE LABELS THAT
APPLY.
YOU KNOW THIS.
IDENTITY POLITICS ARE ONE SIDED.
IF YOU ARE A WHITE CHRISTIAN
MALE WHO VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP
AND BELIEVE IN THE SECOND
AMENDMENT AND HAVE AN AR-15 YOU
ARE PRONE TO VIOLENCE.
IF YOU ARE A WOMAN, NOTHING TO
SEE.
GOOD MORNING AMERICA WON'T EVEN
COVER THIS SHOOTING.
THEY WON'T DRAW A LARGER
NARRATIVE AS A RESULT.
APPARENTLY AN ANIMAL RIGHTS
ACTIVIST.
THIS IS WHAT THE MODERN MEDIA
HAS TURNED INTO, CHEERLEADING TO
TAKE AWAY OUR GUNS AND MOVING ON
IF IT'S NOT RELEVANT.
>> Tucker: IT SEEMS IT CROSSES A
LINE WHEN IT MOVES FROM
ATTACKING THE PRESIDENT
PERSONALLY.
THEY DON'T LIKE TRUMP, I GET IT.
FROM THAT, I GET IT, TO MOVING
OVER TO ADVOCATING FOR SPECIFIC
POLICIES AFFECTING AMERICANS AS
IF THERE IS ONLY ONE SIDE OF THE
DEBATE.
IT MOVES TO FULL ON PROPAGANDA.
>> OF COURSE.
OTHER JOURNALISTS HAVE SAID IT'S
OUR OBLIGATION TO TALK ABOUT THE
PARKLAND SHOOTING.
IF WE DON'T TALK ABOUT IT, THE
CONVERSATION DOESN'T CONTINUE
AND POLICIES DON'T CHANGE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
IT'S YOUR JOB TO REPORT THE NEWS
THAT IS RELEVANT.
A MASS SHOOTING IS RELEVANT.
YOU COVER IT.
THEN YOU MOVE ON.
THEY ARE DECIDING WHAT TO COVER.
>> Tucker: THAT'S RIGHT.
WHAT IS STRIKING, IF YOU WERE
GOING TO PICK A TOPIC THE MEDIA
WOULD LOBBY ON, CAMERA ANGLES OR
LITHE?
>> THEY ARE EXPERTS IN THAT
STUFF.
ANY GROUP IN AMERICA THAT KNOWS
LESS ABOUT FIREARMS.
NICOLE MISTOOK A SODA OPENING
FOR GUN SHOTS.
>> I OPENED MY DIET MOUNTAIN DEW
AND NO ONE JUMPED.
I NEED IT BECAUSE I AM UP AT 6
IN THE MORNING.
NO ONE I KNOW WOULD MISTAKE THAT
AS GUNFIRE.
HOW MANY MEMBERS OF THIS MEDIA
ARE MEMBERS OF THE NRA.
HAVE MANY HAVE FIRED WEAPONS?
THEY DON'T KNOW A SQUAT
AUTOMATIC WEAPON FROM A B-B GUN.
BUT THEY TELL ME WHAT I CAN'T
AND CARRY.
OF COURSE IT'S POLITICAL
ACTIVISM TO HELP THEIR